foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell joined by
Jade warshaw this hour the number to
call is triple eight eight two five five
two two five and if you enjoyed this
show you like the show you listen on a
regular basis I've got a quick ask of
you would you consider subscribing and
following wherever you're listening
leaving a review wherever you're
listening and sharing it with a friend
it takes you about three seconds but it
could change someone's life given the
encouragement they need today and word
of mouth is how this show spreads and we
want to make that happen this year so
let's get to the phones Jordan is
kicking us off in Kansas City Jordan
welcome to the show
what's going on
so wondering about uh my job does not
provide any kind of retirement plan and
was wondering how do I prepare for
retirement in the future when I have a
job that does not give me any kind of
retirement package what kind of job is
this
I'm a full-time Minister oh cool
does your your the church that you're
with they don't offer a 403b or anything
like that
they offer not absolutely nothing just
just my salary and that's it wow you
know so I would probably get first I
would get connected with a smart Vester
Pro because they're going to be able to
really go through all the options with
you off the top of my head I'm thinking
of you as self-employed so my mind is
immediately going to solo 401K sep uh
plan and I would look into some of those
things and see what what you kind of
gravitate towards but at the end of the
day I'd want to work with a professional
because they're going to understand the
ins and outs of it especially since
you're working for a non-profit I feel
like that's kind of the the monkey
wrench in this that makes it slightly
different from any other kind of
independent contractor situation
okay are you married
I I am does your spouse have a
retirement plan through the employer
uh she does not uh she's a stay-at-home
mom to our children okay so there are a
few options you can do which would be a
Roth IRA and you can also do a spousal
Roth and you can contribute you know I
think it's up to 6 500 in 2023 in each
of those and so that's a great way to
get started on this that's going to be
outside of your employer anyone can open
one of those and the other thing you can
look into do you have a high deductible
Health Plan
uh it's a low deductible Health Plan
okay so there wouldn't be an HSA
component with that
uh there's not on the one we're on okay
and all this may change in the future do
you see yourself long term you're going
to stay at this church they're going to
continue to not have any retirement
options
that's your current plan yeah okay
the other option Beyond whatever you
know if you aren't eligible for the SEP
IRA or the solo 401K you can just invest
in a brokerage account this is outside
of retirement which means you're not
going to have any tax advantages but
that money can at least grow for you and
the good news is there's no contribution
limits on that
oh that'd be great and so you will it's
going to use after tax dollars and you
know when you withdraw that money you
will be taxed on the gains but if you
hold it for over a year it'll be
long-term capital gains and so there are
options out there for you I don't want
you to not invest just because there's
no retirement plan through your employer
exactly and but never know what the
future holds and it's always good to
have something coming to back burner
that you can rely on in retirement shows
absolutely
and you what was the professional uh
group that you recommend you go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on Ramsay
recommends they're called smartvestor
pros and these are okay investing
professionals financial advisors all
across the country that our team has
vetted they've got the heart of a
teacher and they're gonna steer you in
the Ramsay way they're not gonna sell
you crappy products and uh that will
help you at least explore your options
for your role okay
there's someone I know that works in
insurance and he was trying to get me
some of those life uh yeah index
universal life whole life permanent life
I always remember Dave Ramsey was and he
was trying to chalk it out though you
could have like eight hundred thousand
dollars by the time you retire and I'm
like no Dave Ramsey says no that's right
good friend do you like this person
what was that do you like this person
okay well just just pray for them Alex
but also stay far away from their
financial advice never trust an
insurance salesperson for investment
advice I know that's right exactly they
will steer you to give them commissions
it's not going to make you rich it'll
just make them Rich Jordan has practiced
the art of forgiveness for them
his pastoral duties wow well hey Jordan
thanks for the call we're wishing you
the best and thank you for your your
literal Ministry what an awesome awesome
field to be in all right let's go to
Alex Alex is in Phoenix Alex welcome to
the show
yes hi hi guys how's it going going good
how are you
I'm doing well just uh another day at
work what's your question today
uh yes I'm 34 years old I have a
two-year-old daughter uh me and my
fiance are looking to get married
probably
um next year it was kind of our plan but
we want to buy a house because we've
been renting for three years now and um
our rent just keeps going up every time
they renew it at least so and uh we're
running out of space and um we've both
been working on all our all our um baby
steps you know she's she still has like
about two thousand dollars worth of
credit card debt but you know I'm trying
to follow you guys as principal I'll
take off all my debt I'm debt free we
have a 10 000 yard emergency fund we
have about another five to six grand in
savings besides that and our lease is up
in December of this year and um I've
talked with Churchill Mortgage they said
to you know um contact them after I had
two years of tax returns and this will
be my second year of become an
independent contractor I own my own
small title business cool I'm just it's
just me there's no other employees
all right so I was just my question is
am I in the right position to be bought
to be looking to buy a house is it the
right time for me is the you know should
I wait longer should we save more money
if it were to be married sooner if it
were me Alex I would hold on because I
know that rent is getting higher and I
know that's tough but out of your own
mouth you said you know I'm trying to
follow the plan I'm kind of trying to do
this right and if you want to follow the
plan we would tell you to wait until
you're married to buy that house
together then you can combine your
finances and from what it sounds like
you said
um your fiance she's got 2K of credit
cards and you have no debt so at that
point once your money is combined you
guys could pay off her credit card debt
and you could have it sounds like uh
fifteen thousand dollars saved because
you said you had 10K and then you had
another five
so you'd have 13 000 saved
um roughly and possibly a little bit
more but some of it's tied in my my
business account so okay have you done
that have you done the research around
what it would take to purchase a home in
your area and what that down payment
needs to be
you know I haven't really talked to like
a loan officer or anything like that I
spoke with one person at Churchill
Mortgage and she said I wasn't ready
that I needed a couple more years of tax
returns and that was like two years ago
I think I would get through this wedding
man I'm saving up you got a big expense
coming up wait until you're married do
not buy a house together before you're
married wait to see how that all shakes
down then once you get a pile of money
enough for a down payment 10 minimum
then we can go ahead with the home
purchase I know you're so close give it
another year or two you guys will get
there you'll do it the right way thanks
for the call this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more first
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm George Campbell joined by Jade
warshaw this hour this is the Ramsey
show you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money at triple eight
eight two five five two two five well
Jade I've been inundated on social media
people have been sending me this video
from a large you know someone in the
financial space who's a Creator yes and
she's been posting her version of the
seven baby steps in a very passive
aggressive Way by Crossing out all of
ours and saying what she recommends
doing instead yeah you're you're kind is
that is that a spot on is that a good
summary that's spot on the video that's
spot on George yeah I'm with you people
have been sending this to me and I
actually follow this person so I was
like I saw it in their feet and I was
like what is happening but it's
interesting because it's got all the
seven baby steps listed and you guys
know seven baby steps let's just go over
them real quick for the few you don't
know this is the Ramsay plan in a
nutshell this is the baby steps baby
step one we're getting a thousand
dollars saved for our starter emergency
fund baby maybe step two is we're paying
off all of our debt except the mortgage
using the debt snowball baby step three
is we're saving three to six months of
expenses in a fully funded emergency
fund baby step four is we're putting
aside fifteen percent of our household
income into retirement baby step five uh
say for your children's college fund
baby step six pay off your home early
and finally maybe step seven build
wealth and give now George it's
important to note that this is a proven
plan over decades I'm talking well the
show's been on 30 years so there you
have it okay it ain't broke it ain't
broke don't fix it so my my girl here
she got beside herself she got she got
she got different she started Crossing
out each one and saying no you don't
have to save a thousand dollars just
start saving just save any amount
perfect you know what that's a smart
goal right there
not
a smart goal is about giving yourself
very clear parameters being specific
just save any amount what is that a
dollar well a dollar will a dollar do it
I don't think it will ten thousand is
that too much just start saving these
until your heart's delight and you want
to know what I love about our plan is it
is for everybody it works for everyone
it doesn't matter who you are it doesn't
matter your income you know what what
your situation is the plan works for you
okay let's look at the second one we say
that step two is to pay off to all debt
except the debt snowball she says no
pay off only the high interest debt and
you can do whatever method works for you
George wow whatever this is wacky wavy
I'm like one of those things outside
that's just one of those in the way okay
just live your truth you know oh yeah
just live your truth don't put yourself
in a box you just start paying off the
debt will it listen whatever method
works for you the reason I need a plan
is because my method ain't working right
so I need someone to tell me what plan
what method actually works there's a
reason that there's experts out here
because you didn't know and that is okay
it's okay for you not to know we're here
to give you a specific plan all right
number three George oh this is a gear
grinder this is hurting me she says you
don't need three to six months you can
do the three six of them the three to
six months of expenses you can do this
while you're completing the other steps
so basically she's taking a play at the
fact that we say you need to work the
baby steps in order do not invest until
you have a fully funded emergency fund
yeah and she's saying you know just
start saving try to get that fully
funded emergency just go ahead and
invest save for the kids college throw a
little bit at the yeah do whatever you
want and and you don't need to have
three to six months before you invest
you can just perfect invest now that way
George you know that way if you have an
emergency just pull from your 401k
that's right horrible ideas HVAC goes
out I wasn't quite there because I was
investing well now I gotta Rob my 401k
or take out a HELOC which is by the way
what most Americans are doing if you
listen to the show they back themselves
into a corner because they don't have
the fully funded emergency fund that's
right and they start doing stupid with
steroids that's right a good teacher
teaches to the class they don't just
teach to the this one little segment of
people you gotta teach to the class all
right here's the next one number five
save for your children's college fund
she just crossed it out and wrote
eliminate debt what does what the heck
does that even mean okay what does that
mean that mean just what kind of
eliminate we don't know just just go to
school do it cash for you know do any
cash I don't know I don't care real
quick
it doesn't even make sense here's my
thing on this okay and then here's the
kicker number six we say pay off your
home early because we want you to build
wealth we want you to enjoy the freedom
that you've worked for then we say baby
step seven build wealth and give she
crossed them all out big red X through
the center and wrote just save and
invest for the long term for goals that
matter to you
okay pick anything out of the clouds
this feels like like you've been playing
Monopoly for too long and you just flip
the board because you give up oh I
flipped the board I was like Jesus when
he walked in the Tabernacle just flipped
those tables over I'm mad George because
this this is the thing you need a plan
and you need to submit to I don't care
what plan I hope you follow the Ramsay
plan but the key is you gotta submit to
the process say I picked this plan I
picked it for a reason my way wasn't
working my your way has not been working
that's why you're still broke that's why
you're listening to the Ramsay show
that's why you're following this girl
online your plan did not work so submit
to a process and follow it and I hear
Dave say it all the time if you do an
ish
it's a wish it's a wish that was the
best alley-oop it was I just tossed it
right away I'm real nervous I was like
if I get this wrong Jade's never gonna
forgive me I forgive you George I was
there too I mean 10 years ago when I
started this Ramsay plan yeah I started
it because my plan wasn't working this
plan of well I'll just take out the
student loans and I'll get this amazing
job at the end and I'll open the credit
card and I'll always pay it off until I
can't because I don't have money for
emergencies and I had to turn to it as a
crutch and I did it for the cash back
and the rewards and the airline miles
but here I am paying 22 interest on four
thousand dollars and I don't feel like
it was worth the reward of the two
percent
and so there's a reason this plan works
it's simple it's straightforward it's
not a Choose Your Own Adventure no it's
not a Chinese buffet just do the plan
and it works everyone thinks they're the
exception George everyone goes yeah but
in my situation yeah but because of my
job yeah but I only make yeah but the
way I grew up yeah but my favorite is
well Dave's plan is only for broke
people well
okay that's very confusing because I
keep meeting people who say I'm a baby
steps millionaire I followed the steps
and all of a sudden I'm a net worth
millionaire yes so that doesn't sound
broke to me bro the facts Don't Lie the
facts don't lie yeah if you if you see
this guys at the end of the day what
we're trying to say here is submit to a
plan and if I could just add one other
thing in here George this is kind of
beside this but
can I just say if you're out there if
you're trying to make your way
making your way downtown walking fast
faces past okay we got that if you're
making your way out here if you are a
entrepreneur your influencer you do not
have to pull anybody else down to shine
all right you don't have to put that
saltiness out there you don't have to
tear anybody else's thing down just do
your thing and you will shine you've got
something for the marketplace there's
plenty of shares for everybody you do
not have to be out here and you don't
have to be okay the truth is people come
at us for clicks because when you put
Dave's name on it all of a sudden you
get 10x the views and 10x to clicks and
so it's kind of a cheap trick it's a
cheap trick but people think they're
making themselves look shiny but I'm
like it's really just dull in your shine
because it's making you look a little
you know salty is all I'm saying you're
looking you're looking salty you're
looking crispy as I like to say wow well
Jade you're doing something really cool
you want to walk people through these
steps week by week by Leading your own
virtual Financial Peace University class
yes George you put your money where your
mouth is this is happening yes this is
happening thank you George because I
almost forgot about the main thing you
got too riled up when is it happening
Financial Peace University guys it is
going to be coordinated by me it's going
to be the class that you've probably all
heard of with with George in the class
and John deloney in the class and Rachel
teaching and Dave teaching and I am
actually hosting that class I'm
coordinating that class so that means
I'm going to be in there in the in the
in the virtual room with you taking your
questions helping you through it this is
starting March 1st click that QR code
it's right there on the screen you can
sign up today guys and we're going we're
going at Mega speed we're doing two a
week give me two hours a week of your
time we are going to change your life I
promise you that we are going to change
nine weeks straight and if you're
listening no not nine weeks George five
oh this is the accelerated Edition
we're doing it in five if you're
listening the link fpu.com get this
number 115-9611
also put that in the show notes if
you're watching you can scan the QR code
join this class it might be the most
epic record-breaking class most debt
paid off most dollars saved and with
Jade hosting I'm gonna join just to see
what happens in there let's go let's get
on my social too I'll be on my social
we'll be answering questions let's do it
I'm so pumped for this all right go sign
up FPU this is your year folks this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm George Campbell this is the Ramsey
Show I'm joining this hour by Jade
warshan we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Jason is up next in Oklahoma City
Jason welcome to the show
hi hey how are you all we are doing
great my friend how can we help
all right well my my wife just left a
job
um and she's looking to roll over her
um 401k and was given what I feel some
very bad advice about rolling it into a
uh 401K Roth or an IRA Ross and that's
my question is
which stuff would be the best one to
take who gave her the advice
um a financial advisor from her new job
how much was in the 401K
200 000. and where are you guys at in
the baby steps or do you have any
Consumer Debt do you have a fully funded
emergency fund
um we do have a fully funded emergency
fund
um at her choice I I thought I wanted to
throw away that the debt we have 19 300
left to pay off on student loans
um we were at 72 000 when we got married
in October cool
so there there is a time and place for
doing that conversion because you're
saying she has a traditional 401K she
wants to roll it into a Roth IRA which
means she's going to pay taxes on that
money to convert it correct and you're
saying this is a bad idea and I would
agree with you uh until you're at baby
step seven with a paid for house now we
have the margin to do that to convert it
so you can do it later so I'll just push
this conversion off until you guys have
a paid for home
okay and also I wouldn't be doing any
any investing until those student loans
are paid off are you guys currently
contributing
I'm not I I believe she
after just okay well you can do your
plan and you can still become debt free
we're happy for you but the baby steps
would tell you that we're pausing all
investing until we've got this Consumer
Debt paid off because it's going to
speed up the process the goal is to make
this short-term sacrifice as short as
possible so that we can live like no one
else later
yes and you guys are on the way to do
that you think you'll pay it off this
year
yes how much money do you guys have in
the bank
um she has 18 000 in emergency funds
um that was the only way I could
convince her to go after this like this
though that was a compromise that I made
what do you mean she I'm confused do you
guys not have you have separate bank
accounts no no no no we have a joint
bank account however I don't feel good
about pulling eighteen thousand dollars
out without permission and vice versa
um
does that make sense so it's your you
all savings account
yeah but she's not on board with using
the money to pay off the debt I see
right she wants to keep in the the
emergency fund in place
I see so she's not willing to go back to
baby step two to pay off this debt she
doesn't want to sacrifice the 18K that's
your baby step three in order to go
backwards and do this thing in order
correct so she's not on board with this
Ramsay stuff at all yeah
no no okay that would be the first step
because right now you guys are running
on two separate tracks and it could be a
recipe for disaster yeah what's your
plan long term for that because if you
guys don't get on the same track that's
you can't sustain that you know if I'm
you and you've had this conversation
many times and it's just not going
anywhere you might want to consider you
know talking to a professional maybe
getting involved talking to a pastor at
your local church maybe picking up a
couple counseling sessions to get you
guys on the same page because you can't
go far like that
correct have you guys been through
Financial Peace University together
we have not we're actually starting it
here in our local Town
um
in February oh awesome did you already
buy it
um I have not we're they're doing one at
our church I believe and I signed up for
it and we're supposed to go through it
then that's great so your wife is on
board with that part
yes oh good okay good that is that's
great that's great I'll do you one
better I'll gift it to you and you can
still sign up for that class but you
won't have to pay for it
okay because I'm that invested in this
relationship and wanting you guys to get
on the same page
so hang on the line Austin will pick up
and we will get you Financial Peace
University for one year you can join
your local class and you can join uh
Jade's virtual class coming up in March
you sure could George you're so generous
I can't you know when it's Dave's stuff
I don't mind you're like it it doesn't
cost me anything but it does feel good
to be generous and help someone along
their financial Journey yeah that's just
what they needed too
so thank you for the call Jason
appreciate it all right let's go to
Orlando Florida Elizabeth joins us there
Elizabeth welcome to the show
hi can you all hear me okay yeah you
sound great
thank you my question is about whether
or not I should move out um I am
currently living in Orlando Florida of
course
um the housing market is kind of crazy
and
um I'm not sure whether or not now would
be a good time to move out I'm currently
living with my parents single mom of
three after a divorce
um and that's why I'm living with my
parents currently but I'm ready to
regain that Independence
um currently on uh baby step number two
um the debt snowball and I've paid off
about forty thousand dollars in the last
two years awesome and have um yes just
student loans left
um of course it's going to be a big cost
having to pay for rent now but I kind of
I'm ready to renewed that Independence
like I said I'm just not sure it makes
Financial sense what's your income
my income is 57. okay how much do you
have left in student loans
uh about 56. okay
you know I like the idea of you getting
you know getting your own footing and
getting out on your own I want to make
sure that you're in a good place to be
able to do that
um and you have got a little bit of
money you know able to do that have you
priced it out to see like what rent is
going to cost what this is going to look
like how it's going to affect your debt
snowball that sort of thing
I have and I do have that emergency
savings and I'm also saving up for the
first last insecurity so I at least have
that ready to go before I move out I'm
also planning to move out with a
relative
um with my older sister oh so you'll
have a roommate that would be a split
cost exactly so how much did you say you
saved for the for this move
um I would say about not completely yet
I'm getting it one more month and I
should have about 4 500. 4 500
specifically and how much is it going to
cost you per month
no more than 1500 is what we decided for
my um portion of the rent
um that feels like a lot comparatively
to your take-home pay because are you
bringing home what 3 500 a month
it's about 42 um 4 200 a month yeah 1500
is a huge chunk of that is there
anywhere that's more affordable because
you're talking about this rent is three
grand are you guys splitting it evenly
or is there rooms for the kids it's 60
40 because I have my kids okay
man that's just a lot even splitting it
it just hurts my brain to think of you
trying to cover all the bills all three
kids what are you doing for child care
remotely unfortunately so I'm able to
keep one of my children home he's young
enough to be able to stay at home with
me the other two are in elementary
school okay do you have any opportunity
to increase your income
um I'm constantly searching for it
um and would like to have some kind of
side something going on I haven't really
found anything just yet but that is
definitely on my radar okay
I'm a little nervous about this it's
it's a big percentage of your take-home
pay I want to see you pay off this debt
and it's going to slow you down in a big
way so I'm wondering is there what's the
off-ramp look like for you to move out
is it a month from now or could you push
it to six months from now and you save
up aggressively and try to knock some
more of this debt out
and I'm actually I was hesitant because
we were thinking maybe there should be a
good time
um my sister's kind of ready to go you
know to make her move back out there as
well
um and so I don't want to hold her back
but at the same time I also and she also
says you know don't do anything you're
not comfortable with and I really am
starting to feel kind of uncomfortable
were there any financially if you can
keep researching are there other places
that are a little bit you know is your
remote can you live a little further out
yeah a couple hundred dollars here is
going to make a big difference for you
yes I mean I actually said let's try
looking for maybe nothing more than 23
um 2300 even we want to try to get it
down to where it's no more than 25 of
your your income so that you're not
strapped and so that you can work this
debt snowball yeah this is a tight
situation I would walk cautiously I
would also create a fake budget and say
can I actually live off of this before
we make this move thank you for the call
Elizabeth we're pulling for you
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey show if
you're a new listener you just caught us
on the radio someone told you to check
out this podcast or maybe stumbled upon
it thanks to the YouTube algorithm gods
and you're going what the heck is this
stuff they're talking about with these
baby steps well we want to help you dive
deeper and so our team created a really
easy to use tool at ramseysolutions.com
just click on the get started button
answer a few quick questions and then we
will help you figure out the next best
step for your financial Journey based on
where you are at today we're going to
give you the right tools and resources
to help you do that ramseysolutions.com
get started all right let's go to the
phones Jason joins us up next and he is
in Columbia South Carolina Jason welcome
to the show
ah thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it absolutely what's going on
um uh my question is I was trying to put
my baby steps in order and I was
listening on my debt and um so I spent
my wife and mine together in there and
my question was when I got to the
interest rates you got to say interest
rate doesn't matter but it seemed like
I'd be because I have I have balances
that are similar like at four thousand
dollar one and a six thousand dollar
credit card and So based off of your
methods I would say off the four
thousand dollar one first but it has
like 13 uh interest on it and the six
thousand dollar one has like 24 interest
on it so it seems like if I was to
ignore the six thousand and pay the four
thousand one I'd be getting a lot of
interest racked up on the six thousand
dollars so I'm just kind of curious as
to why interest rate doesn't matter well
the reason that we teach that is because
a lot of times when you're getting out
of debt it's not just about the math
part of it it's the behavioral part
that's also a huge part of the equation
that many times gets left out right so
we have found uh over the years that the
debt snowball method is actually the
most proven way to pay off debt which is
listing them from smallest to largest
Harvard even did a study about it that
showed that when you get those small
wins because if you really think about
it a lot of times the debt that has the
lowest interest usually is some of the
biggest debt that we have right so
anyway it's great to listen from lowest
to smallest by balance and then you're
getting those small wins quickly and the
more that you get wins the more that you
actually believe that you can do it and
you stay motivated and through the Long
Haul we actually see more people paying
off debt through completion so that's
the way that we that's the reason that
we opt for the debt snowball over
another method which what you're saying
would be the the debt Avalanche method
does that kind of make sense and we
found Jason all this personal finance
stuff it's really Behavior it's 80
Behavior it's only 20 head knowledge and
when you knock out that smallest debt it
actually gives you this little thing
called hope that motivates you to get
the next debt and by the way it freed up
a payment for you to apply to that next
debt on top of all the margin and all of
a sudden you see some light at the end
of the tunnel and so that is the purpose
of the debt snowball it's to create
momentum and so you're right on paper if
you can do the Avalanche method and do
it perfectly then go for it but the
truth is if you had that kind of
discipline then we wouldn't have been in
debt in the first place
right I understand yeah and I I have
never had this discipline I've been me
either brother that's why I I just
submitted to this other guy's plan
because I was like well he's got money
and I don't so let's see if his plan
works I know that's right I did the same
thing man I had 4 000 in credit card
debt I had 36 000 in student loans and
they were all split up into a bunch of
loans and instead of doing debt
consolidation and trying to be fancy and
move the debt around and pay off the
highest interest first I just went I'm
just gonna start attacking these from
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate and man in 18 to 24 months
that's the average time it takes for
people to get completely debt free how
much debt do you have
uh total including Vehicles about right
about 50 000. and what's your household
income
about a hundred thousand okay cool
that's about normal for people to have
half of their income tied up in debt and
that means you can pay this thing off
you're making 100K how quickly do you
think you'll pay off this 50 doing uh
the baby steps with gazelle intensity
right I mean two years from now your
life is going to look totally different
yeah we're talking 18 months right
right
so we can do this thing but it starts
with going all right I'm just going to
go all in on this instead of argue with
myself of why I'm going to do it a
different way or tweak it I'm telling
you go all in for just try it for six
months and see the progress you're
making
and it gets addictive
all right I appreciate it yeah man
thanks so much for the call it's a good
conversation and it's you're not the
first to to ask that question and
truthfully for a lot of people there's
not a great answer because it's hard to
argue with math it is but it's also hard
to argue with hundreds of thousands
millions of people who have done this
stuff and you're like oh but they're
debt free and I'm not so
thank you there it is and my thing is
like when I think about high interest
debt versus low interest debt I mean
usually the stuff with the the smallest
interest is your biggest debt you know
if you're thinking about student loans
that's like the single percentage stuff
usually your car a mortgage if you list
that stuff first by interest rate you're
gonna it's gonna take you forever You're
Gonna Lose motivation if I listed my
first debt by interest rate I would have
had to pay off ninety thousand dollars
in one shot instead of a 200 Little
Store card that I had it doesn't you
know yeah you got to go by motivation
motivation is what keeps you going and I
like you know when you see that interest
rack up it makes you angry and so I'm
okay with that because anger is the fuel
you need to get to debt Freedom it
always starts with anger if you're not
angry and you're comfortable with your
situation and you're happy sitting in
your pile of debt then you're not going
to change but when you start looking at
how much you're giving to lenders every
month through your payments and through
interest instead of Building Wealth for
your family
now you want to punch through a wall you
want to run through the wall like the
Kool-Aid man once you see those numbers
so I want you to be angry because that
tells me you're ready to actually change
once and for all and change your family
tree and change your legacy so that that
is another reason on top of freeing up
payments faster and feeling the progress
I want you to have a little bit of pain
because we have gotten way too
comfortable as a society Americans have
been sitting in their debt in comfort in
la la land wondering why they can't
build wealth blaming the economy in the
White House and inflation and it's the
egg prices now oh God and are we going
to tell the day your payments are the
reason you're broke it's not the egg
prices so stop complaining about the egg
prices and start looking in the mirror
and saying that's the real problem not
eggs being three dollars more than they
were six months ago and that's right so
anywho you got me all riled up George
I'm not adding anything to that I'm just
gonna sit here and imagine you running
through a wall well speaking of Building
Wealth you know anytime the price of
eggs is making the headlines you know
you're dealing with a wacky economy it's
strange times out there man but even
news about layoffs and on-again
off-again recession and the crazy high
interest rates are no reason to give up
on your money goals and we are here to
give you a plan for your money and so I
want all of you to join us for our
Building Wealth live tour as we show you
how to build wealth and actually keep it
so we're going to be in Indianapolis on
February 16th it'll be Dave myself
Rachel and Jade then in Austin Texas you
can go hang out with Dave Ken Coleman Dr
John deloney and Jade and if you are
near or can get to Salt Lake City I'll
be there with Rachel Cruz Dave Ramsey
and Christina Ellis on April the 24th
and we'll round it out in May on May 2nd
in Anaheim California with Dave Ken Dr
John and Christina so we're switching it
up it's a mixed bag and all of those
events are going to be so fun and
tickets start at just 49 bucks or you
can get a four pack of tickets starting
at 175. and all of our fall Building
Wealth events they sold out and so do
not wait to get your tickets you got to
get them now before they sell out
ramseysolutions.com events that's the
place to go to reserve your seats for
Building Wealth live ramseysolutions.com
events and this is your first time on
the Building Wealth tour right Jade it
is I'm so excited I feel like I'm
finally gonna get to meet you guys and
like we're gonna chop it up and it's
gonna be a great time I'm so excited yes
uh the personalities we all hang out
after the event and take photos for fun
and you know they'll sign your books I
don't have any books to sign so I sign
all kinds of random stuff ooh I've
signed t-shirts I've signed you know
hats okay whatever you want it's just
fun it's fun to meet people and hear
their story and little Snippets
obviously we don't have 28 minutes with
each person true but even just that
quick like Hey we're on baby step seven
we paid offer hey we're baby steps
millionaires hey we just paid off
another debt we love celebrating those
wins with you all and the crowds have
been absolutely electric yeah I'm
excited for that just being able to
celebrate where people are on their
journey I think that's everything right
well in like Live Events like we're back
we're doing them now and a lot of people
y'all haven't been doing anything fun
for a while and so there's something
magical about just going somewhere with
a fun crowd of people who are on the
same Journey as you and you go oh we're
not crazy there's a bun there's
thousands of other people who want to be
weird too that's right and that is so
encouraging it's one of the reasons
Financial Peace University is so
powerful because you're around real
people who are on that same Journey so
looking forward to that
ramsaysolutions.com events can't wait to
see you all on the road this spring all
right that puts this hour of the Ramsey
Show in the books my thanks to Jade
warshaw my co-host all the guys in the
booth we've got Austin Ben James Zack
and Andrew and you America thanks for
tuning in today we're going to be back
real soon right here on the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
here if you love the show and you want a
deeper dive on your money Journey we've
got a Weekly Newsletter that gives you
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell hosting
this hour with my friend Jade warshaw
and we're taking your calls America at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Jim kicks us off in Austin Texas
Jim welcome to the show
thank you thank you for taking my crawl
sure how can we help today
uh well I'm looking for some advice on
how to invest 120
000 in cash whoa I am retired in uh 2010
for my first job
I've been working a second job uh
full-time now and over the years
I've saved a lot of money
and I've got uh about three different
bank accounts with money in so I'm
financially good there but I have 120
000 and 10 cans buried in the backyard
that ain't making me no money wow I want
to try to find out
what I can do we finally found the guy
with the tin cans of money in the
backyard wow
let's start with your address where
exactly can we find let's go on a
treasure hunt
Jim's like he's like my name's not Jim
and I don't live in Austin
oh man I believe you Jim I totally I'm
not going near Jim's property so you've
done a great job saving do you have any
debt
I have no debt whatsoever in 2010 I paid
everything off and I work uh uh some for
the municipality that I work for now and
I do a lot of security jobs on the side
and I have been able to really really
save a lot of money the wife is retired
and I should be retired I'm at 67 years
old but do you just like working
I do like working I don't like sitting
at home when I retired in 2010 I stayed
retired six months didn't like it so I
got a job good for you that's awesome
okay how much money do you have do you
have anything invested or is this all
just sitting in checking accounts and
savings accounts
well I have uh two bank accounts two
different banks and then I have a credit
union with some money into these too so
those three accounts is only making
whatever the interest rate is for the
banks oh that stinks so it's not What's
the total of all that money that's in
the banks
uh about 125 000. okay so you got 125 in
Banks and then 120 000 in cash and
you're wanting to invest this
and I wanted to invest at least the 120
000 cash because I know it's not making
me any money well even your the money
that's sitting in those Banks you could
do way better in a high yield savings
account you could be making three or
four percent on that instead of you know
zero to a half percent
okay well that's what the advice I need
and how to do that and what to do to get
to that point and I would tell you I
have a CD for the wife and one of your
accounts for six thousand so there's
another six thousand there and then I do
invest uh in the 457 program I'm not
sure if you're aware of that and how
that works through the county is that
like a deferred compensation
exactly okay and I have about 15
000 in that so do you have any
retirement options through your current
employer
yes what are those options well I'm
drawing an annuity from my first job
uh considerable amount of money I'm
drawing Social Security
because I'm at 66 in two months I'm
going full Social Security there how
much do you have a 401k or anything
through work
no okay so it's the uh two to one match
through the county
I was a tmrs before when I retired from
the other one now it's a Texas Municipal
County Retirement
okay both of them are good retirements
so do you need the income created from
these Investments or are you living off
of the annuity and Social Security Plus
your current income
that's what I'm living off of I don't
really use this other money for anything
other than just sitting there okay even
in the even in the bank accounts
uh just let it sit there
so I would leave enough to have a fully
funded emergency fund and that
high-yield savings account and it sounds
like you'd be more comfortable having
more money in there are you going to
plan on making any big purchases in the
next few years
no okay you've got to pay for house
yes sir great so the full the first
Focus you want to look into is tax
advantaged accounts
meaning things that have some kind of
tax implication that can help you avoid
paying Uncle Sam uh his due
yeah and so that would be things like a
401k or anything Roth so a Roth IRA
what's your household income
uh from it's just me right now so it's
uh let's see 30 30 60
probably around 90 to 100 000 a year
okay
yeah you've got options to make this
work a whole lot more for you than these
bank accounts and so beyond tomorrow the
wife starts on her social security so
we'll have her income coming payday yes
well you guys have done really well I
mean I know it hurts to look back and go
man over the 12 years this Money's been
sitting here it could have grown at you
know eight to ten twelve percent and
instead it just you know couldn't beat
inflation
um but I could kick myself early and sit
there but uh well let's look to the
Future car and and be be uh comfortable
I need some advice and some help to get
some kind of investments in it yeah well
I would for sure you need to connect
with an investing professional who can
walk you through all of your options and
dig into all the details and we've got
some that we vet all over the country we
have some in the Austin Texas area that
can help you if you just jump onto
ramseysolutions.com and click on Ramsay
recommends you can connect with a
smartvester pro and they'll walk you
through hey Jim here's all of your
options that we could do with this money
they're not going to to force you to do
anything you still call the shots
they're just going to educate you on
what you could do and where to invest
that money to help it grow they're
probably going to recommend things like
mutual funds these are groups of
hundreds and thousands of stocks that
can help your money grow with way less
risk than just a single stock when one
company
okay as an example there's index funds
that you could also invest in which are
just tracking you know like the S P 500
tracking the top 500 publicly traded
companies and their growth we're kind of
all banking that's what the economy is
really based on when we look at the
stock market is that S P 500 so there's
a lot of options and you know you you
still got time how old are you
I'm 67. so I mean Jim we still got you
know what 30 years ahead of us here to
to invest this money and let it grow
hope so yes sir you got kids what I'm
looking for uh yes but they're all
married and grown and I've got uh three
grandkids and one on the way I love that
well you know I'm a Bible believer man
and it says a good man leaves an
inheritance to his children's children
and so that's a great goal for you to
have well I do have I do have for the
three that I already have I do have bank
accounts for them set up at the credit
union love it man well you're off to a
great start you've got some homework to
do Jim which is let's research a good
high yield savings account uh there's
there's a ton out there you can look
into Marcus by Goldman Sachs or Ally we
don't have any affiliation with them you
just want to make sure they're FDIC
insured which means your money's covered
just like it would be with that credit
union and those for sure are and then
connect with that smart investor Pro and
get investing don't just leave this
sitting in the checking account breaks
my heart I hear you got six figures that
have been sitting out there for over a
decade man but you've done really well
and being debt free really helps the
situation Jake we love to hear that so
thanks for the call Jim more of your
calls coming up on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
visit blinds.com to save up to 45 off
everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour this is the Ramsey show the number
to call is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Joel joins us up next
in Greenville South Carolina Joel
welcome to the Ramsay show
yeah thanks for taking my call I don't
really have a question I I really just
wanted to share kind of what I've been
able to accomplish and how what I've
learned about my finances in the last in
the last year so I've never really
struggled with credit cards but my
problem's been subscription
um you know the five dollar ten dollar
monthly or Billy once a year type
subscriptions yeah yeah I I figured up
that you know I was paying sometimes two
three hundred dollars a month in those
things because here's what happens they
say ten dollars a month or eight dollars
a month if you pay for a whole year and
then you forget about it a year later in
February suddenly you get a bill for a
hundred dollars and like where'd this
come from I wasn't planning for that
absolutely that's a tough one so what
was your solution
I've been on a year-long war against
subscriptions and canceling any of them
that I can and here's what happens so
you have Netflix and you start thinking
you own those movies you don't you stop
paying they go away right so so it's
like you kind of feel like you're gonna
lose something but I realized if you if
you want to sign up they'll let you sign
up the next the next the next week is so
I've been canceling them as much as
possible I especially hate the ones that
lock you in because you feel like you're
dependent on them like I'm sick of Gmail
and getting all Spam so the storage dude
I just did that Joan I gave Google my
two dollars so they'd stop threatening
me them I'm not going to get email
anymore
no joke I had I had three cloud backup
Services three or four photo backup
Services two music subscriptions five
streaming services it was just it was
wow and a partridge in a pear tree how
old are you Joel I'm curious
I'm in my mid-40s okay and uh you know
it's like some of them I had for years
like uh and and also like your Amazon
Prime studies show that people with
crime subscriptions pay more on Amazon
the longer you have them the more you
pay on Amazon and so it's like I'd had
that for like it makes sense well then
it's like ingrained in your life it's
like you're passing this down to your
kids your Amazon account you depended on
their photo backup you're dependent on
on you know their music service and they
they
etch their way into every part of your
life taking their claws into your thick
of it absolutely I'm glad you fought
back against it Joel and there's uh you
know for the listeners out there there's
a lot of ways they can rally against
this number one is just paying attention
to their money when you sign up for
something thing go ahead and add it as a
line item in your budget and inside of
every dollar our budgeting tool you can
actually add a due date and so you'll
know exactly when that's going to come
due you know exactly when it's going to
happen and you'll know to cancel too I
set calendar reminders all the time when
I sign up for stuff I'll set multiple
calendar reminders for me to cancel it
before you know the time comes due to
pay
I'm a little bit more extreme than that
so what I've started is okay let's say
there's a new season of a show like
stranger things that I want to watch and
I'll sign up for Netflix I'll cancel it
immediately and it will last for that
month it'll still give you the rest of
your 29 day trial yeah and that way
again I'm living intentionally I'm not
letting it it just get get become a
habit and and I find that I'm not using
it because there's so many companies out
there that are banking on people paying
for their service but forgetting about
using it
that's so good so Joel how much were you
actually spending per month like when
you at at your height at the height of
this addiction how much were you
spending on subscriptions
if you count everything including the
Amazon Prime and all that it probably
got up to 150 200 sometimes a little bit
more than that wow
um and again it was it wasn't it it's
it's the death of a thousand paper cuts
right because there's ten dollars here
audible fifteen dollars a month all this
stuff that again those are great
Services if you use them but again I
just found it just became so much and
would just especially with the annual
one you know even a setting reminders
yeah it never came at a convenient time
or oh I have 60 dollars more just
sitting around that I want to spend on
that because or it would be like you
yeah any of these like videos or blogs
about 10 websites that'll change your
life you didn't know existed those are
all like influencers paid in paid
marketing commissions answering you to
sign up for those and you I I'm in the
tech industry I work for a Microsoft
partner I always you know love
technology because like I'm a sucker for
that you know tool that's going to make
me more productive make me a better note
taker maybe you're organized it never
does you don't use the tools you have
now why why is some awesome new AI
powered thing going to make you better
at that thing if you don't use what you
have now well it's they're slick
marketing that always makes us think
I'll be more productive and I got to get
the premium version now because it has
this feature and so that's a tough thing
Joel that I think a lot of you know
especially uh with the newer Generations
gen Z Millennials even gen xers are
struggling with is this just digital
clutter in our life that's keeping us
broke you know I know for Sam and I one
of the things we did is you know because
some of them are slick like apple is
slick you just see the the payment come
out it'll be like 8.99 but it doesn't
say what it was and so exactly never
says what it's for and the same thing
with Amazon you know the charge comes
and it's just you know 27.99 you don't
know what it was for so we really
started getting intentional intentional
about labeling as they came into our
every dollar budget we would label it
and really track it towards where it was
going and then you really see man like
Amazon it's not just subscriptions like
are you paying is it for groceries is it
household goods is it just crap you know
what I mean and I think that when you
label it out and then you go through the
Apple ones and you label them out you're
like okay this is this one was Spotify
and this one was you know the workout
app you can really start to see where
you're spending and where you're
starting to overlap and better than that
just setting a a budget on I am only
going to spend no matter what I only
have 75 dollars to spend on
subscriptions and then like you said
it's like hey I might have to cancel
Paramount plus this month and I that's
right I didn't see the new iCarly reboot
Jade I'm watching Yellowstone George I
don't know what you're watching I'm
trying to watch 1883 out shots fired to
the iCarly fans out there
well Joe I'm glad you fought back
against the system and saved yourself
you know 150 bucks a month way to go
that's great
yeah absolutely and it just it's for one
thing it makes your finances and your
budget so much simpler because you don't
have a million things that say Apple
Apple or Google Google it's kind of like
you know you set up the power off to
your house you try to get the little
meter to stop spinning it never does
same thing it's like just can't get
those to stop and you know that's why
again it's taken me a full year because
I've still been getting and even like
Saturday I saw an ad for some new
streaming service and I almost hit the
button subscribe to think you know I I
want to watch those shows like I don't
have time for that stuff oh yeah I mean
when you have four subscriptions there's
just too much content out there already
and so I feel good it I Get No Greater
Joy than canceling a subscription that I
was not using I know that's right and
can we just say if you're in baby step
two you don't have time for these
subscriptions because you're out here
working that's right you don't have time
to watch Netflix and Hulu and Paramount
plus and and YouTube TV if you have that
much time you are not working enough and
then still complaining that you can't
get rid of the Dead fast enough yes no
so yeah well here's a good point a fun
little exercise for you if you're an
iPhone user just go to your settings
click on your name at the top and then
click on your subscriptions and it will
show you a whole list of all your
subscriptions and you can just tap on it
and cancel it I love that feature so
there we go I just figured I I subscribe
to the storm watch app that I'm going to
cancel right now in front of America for
99 cents a month I was paying look what
because I got freaked out by a storm
coming through and so Nashville severe
weather who I love on Twitter was like
hey you might want to get your own Local
app yeah for this to really track it
it'll you know alarm if a tornado is
coming through by your house you just
saved yourself 12 a year George and
here's the life hack James will
appreciate our producer there's a site
called privacy.com I have no affiliation
with them but you can create basically
one-time use debit cards with limits and
time limits and transaction limits that
are connected to your debit card but it
won't keep charging your bank account
and so if you know you just want to pay
for something once or sign up for a free
trial this is a great way to never
actually get dinged and fall for the
stupid tax so check it out privacy.com I
I'm just using it myself enjoying it and
it's fun time so that's a fun call to
remind us of the sneaky ways we are
becoming broke as a nation and it's from
subscriptions and they add up and if you
start to cancel those you're going to
give yourself a raise in your budget by
100 bucks 150 bucks and then you realize
I can live without this and you sure can
my life is better because I have margin
in my budget love it thanks for the
college roll this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
State and I want you to have a house but
I don't want a house to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jay warshaw
this hour our question of the day comes
from Brent in Virginia here's what Brent
is asking what are your thoughts on
high-yield savings accounts are they
regular Bank savings accounts if so
which ones do you recommend and do you
have to file income tax on interest
gained from them these are great
questions Brent they really are I feel
like that's a Hot Topic lately I know I
get you wouldn't believe how many
messages I get weirdly like per week of
just people going hey what's a good high
yield savings account hysa and the
reason is interest rates on those
accounts have gone way up yes I mean it
was at you know back in 2019 I think you
could get two percent on these accounts
and then it all went downhill yeah to
where you were getting half a percent
and then all of a sudden in the last
year it shot up and so now you can
easily get three percent or more on a
high-yield savings account and here's
what it is it is slightly different than
a Bank savings account they're both
going to be federally regulated both
going to be liquid savings accounts high
yield savings accounts usually just
means these are online banks and they
have less overhead because they're not
brick and mortar stores they have to you
know staff for and build and so they can
offer higher savings rates so there's a
ton of them out there I I opted for the
Ally one I mean I'm this is not to push
them for I mean these are all banks
connection here at Ramsey to any of
these banks these are just kind of
personal preference I know Rachel's an
ally fan I use one called Marcus yeah
and the key is make sure they are
federally regulated so they're FDIC that
means they're insured up to 250 000 per
person on the account so that's one
thing you want to look at the other one
is all the fees and all the minimum
balances and transfer that and so you
want to make sure you're finding one
that has little to no fees is easy to
use will transfer your money quickly
from your savings account over to your
checking account at your local bank or
whatever you do your banking there
another thing to think about which I
think he mentioned here is you are going
to get like a 1099 int for that interest
you know I don't know how much you plan
on stalking away but yeah you'll have to
pay taxes on the interest right yes and
so they will you can log into your
account and download that form I just
did that this week to bring to my my tax
appointment and I mean if you've if
you've got a lot of money in there so if
you're saving up for like a house down
payment yeah you could have some some
serious gains on that if you look at a
four percent on a hundred thousand
dollars for example that's pretty
serious over the course of a year a
decent chunk of change but you know it's
okay I'm you add it to your taxable
income and it's still worth it to have
that money grow for you we take calls
all the time where people are just
watching their money not even beat
inflation just sit there dying in a
normal checking or savings account at
the rate of twenty Thirty forty thousand
dollars so I would rather have that
money grow for me interest you pay is a
penalty so interest in this case is a
good thing because it's a reward so
highly recommend all of you if you've
got a bunch of money in savings move it
to a high yield savings account
it's a great place to store the majority
of your emergency fund if you want to
keep a little bit in your local checking
for those little ankle biters so you
don't have to wait for it to transfer
that's fine mine has a ability to do
wire transfers so if you do need the
money you know same day or next day you
can do wire transfers just watch out
because your local bank may have a fee
to accept that wire transfer something
to look out for very good great question
only I am excited to talk about high
yield savings account so really just
lights me up like a Christmas tree I
know when we saw the question I was like
George this has got you written all over
it I love it you got way too excited
it's a fun well now the interest rates
are back it's a way more fun
conversation true that because now I'm
like what are you doing jump on that my
friend and also there's a lot of
high-yield savings accounts that are
attached to some of these giant uh I'm
gonna call them not scummy companies but
a lot of credit card type companies out
there yeah that's where you got to be
careful that's what I don't I don't toe
over that line now all banks are going
to have debt products it's the nature of
the the industry but it doesn't mean you
have to go to discover and step into the
lion's den because that's basically a
gateway drug for you to give them all
your information so they can Market to
you all of these amazing offers zero
percent on this credit card if you open
today and so yeah I like to find ones
that aren't as heavy on the marketing
side for their debt products I agree I
agree I I don't think that I get any
from mine but they probably know better
they know they know how to come over
here with that show up at my doorstep in
my mailbox I love it well Jade in other
news eggs are all the rage among the
youth my goodness today's America and
now there's like memes we're making fun
of it but there's a hilarious article
that we got sent what is it unbelievable
so the Nationwide egg shortage an
ensuing record price spikes has led
Americans to seek alternative means to
fulfill their appetite and their baking
needs you're never gonna guess what this
is you can actually do George a rent a
chicken coop
yes your face is exactly right they will
bring me an actual Chicken Coop like the
wire fence and everything in my house so
that I can have eggs yes everything that
comes with it I mean they will come they
will deliver it they'll set it up uh
they'll help you set up these chicken
coops they come with a cert you know you
can decide how many chickens you want so
for instance for this one let's see you
can get two rented chickens so you get
two laying hens you get eight to 14 eggs
per week a standard Chicken Coop a food
dish a water dish and 100 pounds of
chicken feed plus your quick guide for
taking care of your rented chickens oh
my goodness and this is oh my gosh 485
dollars for six months so over the six
months you pay 485 dollars the this is
that comes out to about 80 bucks a month
I don't think that math is math in
George that math ain't math right so
here's the deal if they're saying you're
gonna get eight to fourteen eggs per
week out of this let's call it a dozen
for easy numbers right yeah you're
getting a dozen eggs per week for 80
bucks a month that's 20 for a dozen of
eggs yeah no that I told you it ain't
nothing this is fun as like a I guess if
you you've got kids and they want to
know what it's like to be you know sure
and get closer to the food you're eating
that's a beautiful thing yeah but as
like an a hack for inflation this is the
worst hack I've ever heard of do you
kind of know what this reminds me of it
reminds me of when people are driving
their car right they've got their car
they're driving along and the car breaks
down and they're like oh I take it I
gotta get it repaired and they don't
want to pay the the bill to get it
repaired so they just get a new car oh
yes that's kind of like this I feel like
it's oh my gosh chicken prices you know
I don't want to pay the two to three
dollars more let me just go buy a whole
chicken and a whole it makes sense it
doesn't make sense they also have like
an elite package which is 13.85. the Old
MacDonald 1 385 you get a fancier
Chicken Coop and you get 16 to 24 eggs a
week
I don't even know I just looked at my
local like there's a you know there's a
little frou-frou grocery store nearby
called Sprouts yes here in Franklin
Tennessee and I just checked on their on
their page how much eggs are going for
it was 339 for a dozen of eggs it's
really not that serious George and I
even looked at like okay what are the
really bougie expensive you know the
chickens had a great life they saw the
sunshine they took them to Disney World
they laughed they cried even those eggs
were 8.99
you know what I think it it depends on
where you go because I know in some
states it's like super you know who
always comes at us as Canadians they're
always like well in Canada eggs are 19
for and I'm like listen I can't speak to
Canada y'all are y'all are doing things
differently out there you got poutine
your prices are out of whack not poutine
George I'm not coming after poutine I'm
just saying they do things differently
well here's what here's what I want to
get to I feel like in the economy things
happen and we just go to extremes like
remember in like 2008 gas prices were
crazy and everybody started buying smart
cars oh yeah like those ridiculous teeny
tiny cars and it's like this is the
solution to our problems a terrible idea
are people just like freak out and start
buying a bunch of gold and I'm like now
the eggs are expensive let's just we're
buying chicken wire we're buying whole
whole chickens whole coops this is a
symptom of something deeper if you're
really frantic right if you're really
freaking out about this if this if this
egg shortage is in the price increase is
if it's breaking your bank there's
something further beneath the surface
you're complaining about egg prices
going up you know 50 60 okay that
amounts to three bucks for a dozen of
eggs yeah
that's probably 20 bucks Max a month for
y'all but then you're okay sending a
lender 500 bucks for that car payment
yeah and you're okay sending Sallie Mae
400 bucks over here for your student
loan payment there's a problem look at
the real problem
it's your debt it's not the eggs folks I
never thought I'd have to say that
sentence out loud yeah if you want to
overcome this it's your debt we will
survive the bird flew egg shortage of
2023 and you can become debt free and
create margin in your budget and then
you're not really all that concerned
about egg prices you just adjust the
budget and move on with your life
sorry we had to explain that to you guys
oh George here we go there's my dad joke
for the day this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour
[Music]
out there you've already got a lot on
your plate being both a parent and a
teacher but you don't have to add money
expert to that list to teach your teens
how to win when it comes to money we've
got a brand new foundations and personal
finance homeschool curriculum where our
personalities teach this complex money
stuff for you they'll cover real life
skills like how to budget save invest
for the future and your kids will learn
everything you wish you learned about
money when you were their age plus the
curriculum comes with everything you
need to make your life as a parent and
teacher so much easier you're going to
get lesson plans activities transcripts
everything's already created for you so
you can focus on raising teens who are
confident about money and prepared for
the real world
so if you want to check this out
foundations and personal finance
homeschool curriculum just go to
ramseysolutions.com
homeschool to learn more that's
ramseysolutions.com homeschool
good stuff there all right let's go to
the phones Kelly is in Brookfield Ohio
Kelly welcome to the show
thank you for taking my call no problem
to do it how can we help today we love
the Ramsey Show so I'm calling basically
about
um my boyfriend and he has done a great
job at saving and has made huge changes
and I'm going to tell you about them and
I believe that he can be debt free this
year including his house and he wants
your opinion on what to do with the
money and I want to see if it matches
what I say that oh this is a fun game it
is okay
hit us with some facts
okay
um so
that was 16 5 and he has a jeep that
he's going to be getting rid of so it's
amazing
um so right now in the bank after he
bought this truck he has 66 899 dollars
okay
and he has Consumer Debt which is his
Jeep a student loan and a tractor that
is forty five thousand and sixty dollars
and when we were talking about this I
said
um
I felt that you should he should go
ahead and pay off all that and he's like
well I don't want to pay my G block
because I want to sell it and I'm going
to be selling it before June and
um that's where I feel like maybe you
guys could help with that and also he
has a student loan that
um has like 10 000 left on it and I'm
like he thinks he's like gonna or he's
hoping for like this forgiveness and I'm
like oh no
so Ali Kelly Kelly
there's there's some issues here okay so
he has the money he could pay this all
off today and still be left with 21 000
in the bank
yes and that's actually more than his
monthly expenses like his emergency fund
I think should be about ten thousand
dollars yeah he he'll be just fine but
he wants to hang on to this debt so does
he understand that when he sells the car
he has to pay off the loan anyways
um well say that again I'm sorry when he
sells the car he has to pay the loan to
get the clean title
the Jeep yeah he would but he's thinking
he's just gonna pay it off like when
somebody pays him because he thinks I
I'm pretty sure he has about 10 to 15
000 equity in this Jeep what happens
when they use car market keeps on
dipping and all of a sudden he's
underwater
while he continues to make these
payments on a vehicle he's not even
using
yeah like he I I don't know that's why
I'm like just talking to you guys about
it I want to know I want to know where
is he at well you're saying you want to
see if his advice matches ours Our
advice is obviously to pay this all off
today be done with it for yourself of
those payments
and the stress related to all this debt
and move on with your life
it's the simplest solution of all time
he's got the money sitting there with
plenty left over
how long have you have you guys been
dating
for like 18 months and he honestly has
made huge changes like he doesn't get
crappy every day he like we don't go out
to eat near as much like we so you feel
like you're influencing him towards a
positive direction financially
yes yes absolutely and I feel like he
should just go ahead and follow these
steps but it's like he wants to not let
go of his savings and he says he's like
I've never had that little bit of
savings ever and I'm like but after you
pay those payments off and all that
that's gone look how far he has the
illusion that he has 66 000 really he
doesn't because he owes people a whole
bunch of money is he interested in
Financial Peace University
honestly I was a coordinator and I've
had him watch it he's watched all the
lessons and he still wants to hang on to
the debt
um
I feel like it was in just him and I
having this um watching the videos and
maybe it wasn't super impactful at the
beginning because maybe he didn't feel
like it was is important would he go
back through it again when did you guys
go through it
um actually just a couple months ago oh
boy it did not stick so it's uh I just
have to ask are you kind of trying to
you're trying to see is this guy
marriage material if you guys can get on
the same page of money and you're really
trying to see man I hope I can get him I
hope I hope you get him too
um but you know I think I think the
thing is is he's just he makes a a very
good living and our incomes are not
combined of course I'm just saying like
I think that you could literally have
your house even paid off by the end of
this year yeah I don't think he wants
that he that's the thing we agree with
vision for his future he's hoping the
government's going to take care of him
yeah based on what you told us we agree
with you Kelly but your guy he's he's
got a whole different methodology in his
mind and I I think it's admirable that
you're trying to show him this that
you're giving them information and that
you're teaching you can lead a horse to
water but you can't make him drink and
you can just keep setting that setting
that ball out there for him and maybe
eventually he will but you need to set
yourself a time limit and then you might
need to sell the horse no I know that's
right
stallion very controversial advice
we actually have another
um meeting set up with an investor Pro
which we I contacted and we're gonna
talk with them because he wants like his
top priority is to save for retirement
and I said okay then you have your
emergency fund already in place now you
need to start putting your full 16
because he right now is only doing three
and he needs to be doing zero until this
debt is paid off yeah Kelly you're right
you're gonna preaching to the choir can
you preaching to the choir here here's
some math you can do with him add up all
of his payments plus interest and said
hey what if you invested that over the
next 30 years and just show them what
that number would turn into
okay okay because that'll put his money
where his mouth is if he's saying I
really want to invest for the future
imagine a life without payments and
repurposing that money instead of
throwing it to lenders he throws it to
his future and if he still doesn't care
then he's lying he doesn't care about
his future
or he just wants to do it his way
which we think is the wrong way
I know and I do I have to say like he
has done really well for himself even
though you can out earn your stupidity
plenty of people do it yeah you can keep
making money and he you know what he can
still have a fine life but right now
your values are misaligned and it's a
red flag for sure I'm not saying that it
won't work out with this guy I hope it
does he sounds like a great guy we're
not here to bash him uh he's very normal
and you have decided to be weird and
it's hard for those two to be compatible
we need to have two weird people if this
thing's gonna work
if I'm you Kelly I'm taking this advice
I'm going to give it a couple of more
give the old College try and keep trying
to feed him like George said like do the
math like sit down and look at this
thing but then give yourself a time
limit and go if my guy doesn't if it
seems like we're not aligned on this
area start digging deeper and see if
there's you know see if it's worth you
going forward with this because this is
something that is going to be critical
if you guys go forward
um with getting engaged and even on to
marriage and dig in and ask him hey why
are you hanging on to this and if he
goes well the student loan show him the
stats on student loan forgiveness it's
bleach show them how Bleak it is
Congress trying to get this thing
through and how little chance it is of
him getting a student loan debt cleared
completely it's not going to happen
and so you can go back through FPU you
have access to it still so I'd go back
through it with him and say I'm going to
give this one more College try buddy and
I really want to make this work but I
need you to show me that you really care
about our future and what it relates to
money so thank you for the call Kelly it
was a fun one and thank you all for
listening to this show America it puts
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to Jade warshaw all the
folks in the booth will be back real
soon
[Music]
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host George Campbell
Join This Hour by Jade warshaw we are
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Ted is
kicking us off in Jacksonville Florida
Ted welcome to the show
hey guys how are you guys doing today we
are doing great a little pep in our step
how can we help
[Music]
um so I
knew you would and my wife and I have a
pretty good chunk of change that we
would kind of like to know what to do
with it and uh but we one little side
note we are potentially going to get a
house at some point in time so we want
to maybe have that in a safe spot as
well awesome well congrats on on
marriage how's that been going how long
ago was this so far so good it's uh just
been about a year nice
exciting do you guys have any debt
uh no we are completely debt free love
it all right so let's talk about this
chunk of change how chunky is it
pretty chunky we're we're very blessed
and it is uh north of the half a million
dollars wow okay where did this money
come from
it's uh really just been the job market
down here in Florida and the housing
market uh my wife and I moved together
and we were able to between her home and
um some finances that I've had that we
were able to combine and have that chunk
of change well give yourself some
trouble so she had some equity in the
home when she sold it and then you've
been saving like a crazy person
uh yes and uh granted I've had some help
with my family uh through some
inheritance but at the same time we both
make over 200 Grand so we've just been
saving like crazy ever since so what's
your household income today
uh it's north of 220. Awesome
okay so you're talking about what to do
with this savings and you mentioned the
goal of buying a house are you guys
renting currently
no uh I own uh my Home Free and Clear
whoa how old are you two
uh we're both in our early 30s oh my
goodness y'all are different
you guys are really different
what's the house worth left beyond
belief yes
yeah so we're Ultra thankful but it's
it's pretty amazing and uh that's why we
just want to make sure that we're not
doing anything ridiculous and you know
hoping to do something in the future
that we are just like wow we it's like
the lottery so we just want to be smart
with it I love it what's the house worth
that you have right now
and it's
it's probably about three four hundred
okay and then you've got 500 000 in cash
just sitting in the bank and a
high-yield savings accounts yes love it
great and then any other retirement
accounts
he has hers through her work and I have
a Ross I've maxed it out uh for every
year okay so you guys are in baby step
seven which means you can invest more
than fifteen percent and so I would at
your age I would just take advantage of
as much investing as I can and that
might look like with your income you
know Mega backdoor off with after tax
contributions to your 401k do you have
that through your employer
uh I do not but she does okay so that's
one place you can sock away a whole
bunch of money also do you have an HSA
either of you
uh yes she does okay so we can max out
her HSA and that money can be invested
and that can be used as kind of a side
investing retirement tool which is
really cool and beyond that I mean you
have brokerage accounts of course you
can sock that money away in outside of
retirement and you'll pay taxes on the
growth of that over the years
but that's if you run out of all tax
advantage options you can always turn to
that brokerage account
and uh so I know I I've listened to you
guys a lot where uh so I maxed out my
Roth obviously every year would it be
smart for me to open an IRA as well on
top of that oh absolutely yeah max out
IRAs now you may not be able to
contribute to a Roth because of your
income limits
so you need to look at that look into
that if not you can still contribute to
the traditional IRA you may not be able
to deduct it deduct it on your taxes but
it's still going to be a great
retirement option for you
okay and you can do a backdoor Roth
which is where you convert that those
funds to the roths side and pay the
taxes
okay so are you working with a financial
advisor right now
uh no not currently that would be my A1
for where you guys are at wanting to
maximize this money in this amazing spot
I would get in touch with one of our
smartvestor pros at ramsaysolutions.com
and they'll be in the Jacksonville area
and they can walk you through all of the
options you could do with this and then
you'll make the decision on where that
money goes but outside of investing
let's talk about giving and spending do
you have any goals in that Arena
uh so what I'm kind of just starting to
do is whenever I'm at a gas station I'll
I'll kind of just seek out you know a
vehicle that doesn't look like someone
is having the best day
and I'll I'll buy their tank of gas and
no questions asked oh that's awesome
well I love that you have the the margin
with your time and money to even look
around for those opportunities to give
and so I would focus some of it on
giving with this savings with future
income I would focus some of it on
spending set some goals and say hey
here's the places we want to travel to
we want to upgrade we're doing that yeah
and so have fun with it too because
sometimes people like y'all that are so
focused on saving and investing you're
so good at that but it's hard to let go
of the money and just enjoy it too so
I'm glad you have some balance there
this is fun my wife she um she is always
been kind of a penny favor too and uh so
you know that's what's made this whole
marriage like pretty unbelievable where
our goals are pretty aligned and we have
daily conversations of what we could do
how we can give wow yeah it's a huge
factor in why you guys are so wealthy at
a young age because of those shared
values and shared Vision shared goals
man you guys are running a million miles
an hour and there's living proof
right and then on the housing side do
you want to upgrade in-house eventually
we do yes and uh that's kind of why
we're you know holding off on
potentially meeting with some financial
advisor just because we you know want to
be able to have that cash on hand to put
towards the house and then after that
that's when I'm gonna hone in you know
meet with a financial advisor and then
just invest like crazy from there I mean
would you say that's fair yeah I mean
because you may just go hey we want to
use this 500 plus our homes worth 350
we're going to get an 850 000 house
there's nothing wrong with that either
you got plenty of time to keep investing
you have an amazing income no debt if
you just keep this up you're I mean
you're already probably baby steps
millionaires I imagine your net worth
yeah we're close
it's yeah I would say we're pretty dang
close I love it but uh yeah bless beyond
belief and you know for a lot of people
that are struggling out there like you
know just always keep a positive
attitude because you never know who's
going to be at the gas station to help
you out that's so true well Ted I love
your heart what a beautiful picture of
what this looks like when you get on the
same page and you start your marriage
off in the right foot completely debt
free money in the bank you have options
you've got freedom man you've got joy
you can give like no one else live like
no one else thank you so much for the
call I'm inspired talking to you this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
what's up America this is the Ramsey
Show I'm George Campbell joined by Jade
warshaw this hour
uh Jade this has been a Hot Topic
among the Youth of America among the
Millennials and here's the headline I
want to get your take on this
Millennials are living with their
parents at higher rates than past
generations and they're not ashamed and
here's the stats since 2020 adults aged
25 to 34 are living at home at higher
rates in past Generations said the
Census Bureau and of course since the
onset of the pandemic young Millennials
are living with their parents at rates
that have not been seen since 1972 and
they seem to be in no rush to move out
I mean that is the fact I definitely you
know here's the thing
I if I felt like people were really
taking that money
paying off debt
uh stashing away you know for a down
payment and doing well with this money I
might say okay you know live at home
fourth season stack up you're like
there's a time when that works
culturally there's those situations as
well but we know it says that um 48 of
these people that are living at home
with their parents they are spending a
lot of this money on luxury items oh
called out handbags watches
Gucci Gucci belts George you know what
I'm saying yeah this is the part that I
have a problem so Morgan Stanley did
some research about discretionary
spending and that's what they're finding
is that the no rent that money that
would have been used towards rent is
going to some discretionary spending
that may not be the wisest move yeah I
just don't see I don't see how I again I
just don't see how this is really and
that's what it's cracked up to call it
out that is the 48 was folks that are 18
to 29. yeah saying the older Millennial
counterparts they're living at home
means things like you're talking about
saving for the down payment waiting for
the high mortgage rates to come down
housing prices prioritizing spending on
experiences like vacations and concerts
rather than material Goods I still think
there's a time limit there's got to be a
time limit on this thing George yeah
this whole like well I'm just gonna live
at home until the economy cools down
that's a recipe for disaster absolutely
we're not here to bash listen if you're
in your 20s or even in your 30s and
you're with Mom and Dad I'm not here to
yell at you but I do want you to have an
exit strategy and a plan to get out of
this and usually it means let's get our
income up let's get out of debt let's
start spending less this is a great time
it's like the student loan pause it's a
great time to pay off your student loans
yes not the time to go party because
there's no payments I agree so uh I
moved out when I was 20. and I moved
across the country and finished school
when did you move out I moved out so I
lived on campus for the first three
years of college then I was engaged my
final year of college and I didn't want
to go back and live at home so I lived
in an apartment where there were not
enough rooms for me so I lived on the
couch and I couch surfed until I got
married and then I moved in with the
great Sam warshaw I love it when we were
married yeah and I when I moved out I
mean I had roommates up until I was
married basically and so there's nothing
wrong with that you have roommates right
now they're just your family and I'll
tell you I miss living at home because
mom's doing the cooking and she was a
very nurturing mother and so she was
like I'll do the laundry and but it
stunted my growth like I was getting
lazy even when I go home for a vacation
I'm all of a sudden transported back to
my childhood self and I have no
discipline and I'm sleeping in and you
just revert to your former younger
version of yourself do you know what's a
better version of this that will really
keep you motivated and I can say this
because I did it instead of living at
home George
go get roommates
just go get roommates you can still save
a lot of money maybe not as much money
as having no rent but get some roommates
pay a little bit a month and then you're
gonna feel more hey you're going to feel
more independent but you're also going
to feel more like man I gotta get out of
this situation so I can live by myself I
think the home environment it's too
comfortable I wish Dave was here because
I can hear him in my head so comfortable
an eagle that doesn't leave the nest is
called a turkey a turkey you can just
picture him saying that and that's
exactly right there's a level of dignity
you get when you move out on your own
and you're paying your own bills and
it's on you that level of responsibility
while scary for some financially man it
just makes you feel like a whole
independent person absolutely and I know
here's the thing I know there's some
married couples who are living with the
in-laws or living you know at home can I
tell you when Sam and I got married uh
we were living by ourselves but we
wanted to save money on rent and we got
roommates as married couples whoa we
lived on the upstairs of the townhouse
and the other people lived on the bottom
half of the townhouse we did it for one
year
saved 600 on rent let's go let's go I
love it well hey you can do this and
we're here for you if you're one of
those Millennials living at home and you
want to get out we can show you the path
financially how to set yourself up for
Success all right let's go to the phones
Rhett joins us in Salt Lake City Rhett
welcome to the show
hello thanks for having me absolutely
how can we help
um so I signed up for a universal index
life policy when I was 24
um so five years ago and now I'm
wondering if I should cancel this policy
or if I should wait five years and
cancel when I don't have any more uh
early cancellations the surrender fees
yeah yeah that's the name man so when I
think of this situation I think of the
term sunk cost fallacy where you stay in
something because you put money into it
and you just go I'll just keep putting
money money into it until maybe it makes
more sense but I'm getting out of this
thing today and before you do that make
sure that you have term life insurance
in place
okay do you have term
um I am just about to finish one up
right now okay and for everyone
listening for the good of the listeners
out there what are you paying for this
universal life insurance policy
it is 2 45 a month
um but I also have uh 250 000 disability
tied into it and a ten thousand dollar
child writer oh wow
okay and what's the death benefit
um if I were to die today it's worth 5
um but originally timing out those for
500 000. okay and then the cash value
has not built up much at this point
so it's worth thirty thousand the cash
value but as far as canceling it's only
worth 2 800 today
and if I wait five years it's worth 23
000.
ouch so what's this thing going to cost
you to cancel today
um
they'll pay me 2 800 bucks to cancel
today and how much have you paid into it
over those five years
um roughly 14 5 14 500 okay so we'll
call this uh you know a ten thousand
dollar stupid tax and we'll move on with
our life and we'll get term and over
those five years you're already gonna
make your money back just by getting a
term life policy that's you know five
percent of the cost of this thing
right so just for fun
um I went and got a quote for a Term
Policy that had that 250 000 disability
and the ten thousand dollar child writer
okay it's roughly 83 a month so I guess
my main question would be is the
disability worth it for me as a
self-employed
person
because you're self-employed you're
looking to get the disability insurance
in case something happens to you and
you're unable to work but you're still
living
yeah
uh I would look at the price without it
and see if it's worth the risk for you
are you in a high risk position
no
then I wouldn't I wouldn't worry about
that side of it
um the 10K child Rider what's that for
um just as one of my children didn't
pass away before me
but why would you need life insurance on
them they're not providing an income
um but that was just something that I
signed up for when I was 24. okay so
we're not I you don't need that as part
of this new Term Policy so I would price
it out and go hey what is it going to
cost for a half million what's your
income today
um it's about 150. okay a year I still
think I mean so 150 a year we recommend
10 to 12 times your annual income so
that would put you at about 1.5 million
yeah so I got a quote on a million term
and it was 30 a month that man that's a
heck of a price compared to what you
were paying for half of that death
benefit
right yeah I I guess the main thing that
I was tied up on is if I paid 15 000
more into it over the next five years
it's worth 23 000. I I'm I'm not taking
that deal it feels like a gambler in
Vegas being like just let me work at the
slots man I got we're going to get out
of this thing I'm canceling today this
thing is a rip-off and the entire
universal life insurance industry exists
or basically rip people off and make
them think it's a wise investment for
their future when really you're just
paying insane premiums that make those
sales people giant commissions for a
long time so get term then cancel that
universal life policy my friend thanks
for the call this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show
and about this time of year we get
flooded with calls because everyone is
looking for a fresh start with their
money they're not where they want to be
financially and if that's you you can't
wish for things to change and just
expect it to happen you've got to do
some things differently when it comes to
money you've got to have a plan and we
can teach you that plan in Financial
Peace University this is the course that
will help you rethink how you manage
your money where you're going to learn
our proven plan to beat debt and build
wealth plus you're going to have access
to our financial coaches to help you
every step of the way nearly 10 million
people have taken FPU it's the same
course that Jade and I went through that
changed our lives and if you follow this
plan it can change everything and you
can do this thing and today is the
perfect time to start and it's because
right now we are offering Financial
Peace University get this 69.99
but only through the end of the month
that is seriously I've worked here for
10 years Jade I've never seen that price
on Financial Peace University so if
you've been on the sidelines going uh
I'll wait this is this is it don't wait
any longer by the end of the month this
thing's gonna be over so this year you
can have more piece of a piece in your
finances and your life don't wait to do
this get this limited time offer on
Financial Peace University at
ramsesolutions.com deal that's
ramseysolutions.com deal and if you've
been through it this is a great
opportunity to gift it to someone else
at a great price as well
ramseysolutions.com deal all right let's
go to the phones Nick joins us in Newark
New Jersey Nick welcome to the show
hey guys thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help
so I'm 24 years old I've been out of
college for it'll be two years in May
and I'm still living with my parents uh
I'm trying to move out by mid-summer
September is kind of my goal
um but I have that of course I have
um 65 000 in private student loans for
college in 1905 in federal and that
starts up again in I think October and I
do have a car loan that's about fifteen
thousand dollars uh that I pay 296 a
month for and I have 300 a credit card
debt really not not much at all I can
pay that off
um I make salary and commission so
um and I also have a side hustle so I'm
in the ballpark of 50 000 a year it
really you know kind of depends I would
just say that's a good estimate
um
I'm in Tech sales I work remote
okay and my and my side jobs at a golf
course okay and I'm contributing to my
401k you know three percent I have a
Roth IRA open I'm I'm waiting to add to
my a little bit more device high-yield
savings to uh start contributing to it
but basically my question for you is uh
what is your advice for my situation to
be able to move out uh securely in you
know let's say mid-summer September I
also I don't know if I mentioned I have
22 000 high yield savings my goal is
about 28.30 by May and what's the goal
in the savings side
uh in savings the goal is uh around
thirty thousand dollars by may just
about why what's the why behind that
I think mentally I just I like seeing a
big number in there for security it's
kind of just I'm more freaked out by the
other number your debt amount compared
to your income is scary dude
yeah yeah I have a feeling you're you're
not gonna like the color but yeah so
what kind of car is this
originally during covet I was working uh
I was a I was working at a supermarket
so I couldn't really do anything so I
bought an Audi A5 and I've got a good
deal on it and I sold it uh after about
a year and I made five thousand dollars
off of it but I I now have a 2019 Jetta
that I bought almost a year ago when
cars what's it worth it weren't
right now
probably like 14 and no 13 and
you still owe 15 on it
yeah okay well you called our show we're
going to give you our advice and I mean
it's going to be the baby steps which
means we're going to clear most of your
savings to throw at the debt and if you
did that you could clear the credit card
and the car loan today
and still have money left over right
yeah I could probably have like five
something you know what does that do it
frees up your credit card payment and
your car payment which you said was
about 300 bucks a month
yeah it's 296 yeah and now we're just
attacking the student loans which while
they're on pause means you can actually
make progress because it's not accruing
interest
yeah so the question is how much of the
student loan date can we knock out by
the Fall before you even move out
problem if I really tried like 10 000
honestly I really tried so
possibly a little more
well the the advice is I want you to get
out and I think you can you'll probably
have to get a roommate I'm imagine if
you're going to stay in New York right
yeah I'm definitely open to that okay I
thought about leaving Jersey too for
maybe Phillies that are very affordable
there so okay well start doing your
research on hey what is rent going to
cost and how do I get my income up
because Wherever I Go it sounds like
you're going to be on the coast these
are high cost of living areas I know
Philly may be slightly cheaper than
where you are but it's still expensive
compared to most of America
yeah New Jersey's definitely isn't the
cheapest
so the question is you can keep doing
the Nick plan and that's fine and you'll
hopefully get there one day but I would
rather you follow the Ramsey plan and go
how do we knock out this debt with Focus
intensity which means we're pausing that
three percent investing contribution
until we're debt free with a fully
funded emergency fund
yeah because that's going to free up
another little chunk of your money
so the question is where can we free up
as much money as possible to attack this
debt as aggressively as possible so you
would start with the car and the credit
cards and then I mean I would look if
you want to sell the car and go buy
something way cheaper with the money you
have in the bank you can do that
because right now just based on your
income this is going to take you longer
than two years and anytime it's going to
take someone longer than two years to
get out of debt I think more drastic
measures are needed
yeah
and you can't sell your degree
unfortunately what was your degree in
uh communication I'm in Tech sales now
I'm I am looking for you know to make
more money but I definitely am but yeah
I would for sure look at different Tech
sales job because you can make some
crazy money in Tech sales so the fact
that yeah you're getting 50k between the
side hustle and the tech sales job makes
me think uh there's something else out
there for you yeah what do you think
Jake okay am I off here I think you're
right on George I think you know in
these situations it's it's easy to kind
of like we talked about earlier wanting
to do kind of an ish plan do the Nick
plan but I really think that in this
case you need to stick to The Proven
Plan and just work these baby steps
yeah absolutely I completely agree and
you'll have that savings account back up
in no time once we get out of debt and
if you can get your income no that's the
most I've ever had to save I love
looking at that people get emotionally
attached to their savings and it really
is an amazing thing because most people
have never seen that kind of money
sitting in their bank account and so to
drain that
man it hurts but yeah it's a security
thing yeah you're excited about 22 when
we're looking at you know 80k sitting on
the other side in debt accruing interest
and that part makes me angry go add up
all what all your payments are plus the
interest you would pay for the remainder
of the term and it's going to make you
want to punch something
oh yeah every every month it's let's say
a little over a thousand you know if I
hadn't if I had no debt I could easily
move out right now in my opinion but
agreed well we just did a whole segment
on Millennials unable to move out it's
feeling like they're unable to and it's
largely due to debt and we can blame
again cost of living is wild and you
live in a high cost of living area and
inflation is tough and the housing
Market's tough and the rental Market's
tough but you know what else is tough
paying someone a thousand dollars a
month for the past I know that's right
so yeah that is your best tool to fight
back against all of this craziness and
inflation and you can do that but you
need margin and the only way to do that
is to get out of debt spend less and
make more are you doing a consistent
monthly budget right now
yeah I actually have a spreadsheet I'm
staring at it right in front of me
actually I love it well I'll do you one
better and gift you every dollar premium
for one year that's our budgeting tool
it beats a spreadsheet I'm no Excel Wiz
I don't like to jump in there it gives
me the heebie-jeebies and so jump onto
every dollar and plug all of your
numbers in there's some great premium
features as well like the paycheck
planning tool you can use to make a plan
for every single one of those cents
coming in Nick and if you do that you're
gonna start to find areas you've been
slouching we call them money leaks
around here where you got yeah that
subscription I don't need it eating out
I don't need it I've got goals to get
out of mom and dad's house I'm gonna do
whatever it takes to get there man thank
you for the call we're pulling for you
and for all of the Millennials out there
who are going how much longer do I gotta
live with Mom and Dad listen you can get
out but your payments are killing you
it's not the egg prices it's your
payments get out of debt use the debt
snowball this stuff works every time you
work at 18 to 24 months is the average
time it takes for folks to get out of
debt using this method you can do this
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsay show our scripture of
the day John 15 12. my command is this
love each other as I have loved you
Jackie Chan once said in work and in
life no matter how smart talented and
beautiful you are you also have to be a
good person we have to treat one another
well and really mean it everyone can
tell if you're doing it out of genuine
concern for them or if you're just
faking
let's go to the phones Shay joins us up
next in Jackson Mississippi Shea welcome
to the show
how you doing um
good
I'm great what's going on
um I have a question I have 25 000 in a
bank that I had in a CD
um so a four-year CD it earned maybe
like 200 a little over two hundred
dollars so I went to the bank to put it
in another CD which would earn four
percent but these um financial advisor
at the bank say that I should invest my
question is should I invest through the
bank I do have a financial advisor for
Roth IRA that I got maybe two years ago
um should I just invest that money with
him or should I invest with the bank
well it depends
um you know my first inclination is to
kind of find out where you are in the
baby steps because the way we teach you
know might determine a different
strategy for what you currently had with
this money so right now do you currently
have any debt
no no debt I love it debt free and do
you have any money that you're able to
just kind of liquid easy to get to for
your three to six months emergency past
this 25k or is that it
no outside of the 25 I have about 54. oh
wow very good is that where is that
sitting
just in savings account okay and that is
that above and beyond six months or is
that right at it
no this far above and being on six
months so what is your goal with all
this money
um I will
um 50
I feel like I'm a little bit
about the investment because I started
late so I'm just trying to see what's
the best um strategy I guess to kind of
grow my money the best I can is this
quote unquote late stage have you been
doing any investing previously how much
do you have in your nest egg
um I have invested with my job I have
about 92 000 with my job and then like I
said I just got a Roth in a financial
advisor for a Roth IRA about two years
but I think it's only maybe four
thousand in there okay what's your
income
um 40
000. and you have a 401k through your
employer
okay do they have a Roth option there
for the 401K
I doable I think they do okay I would
look into that that could be a good
solution for you and you could do all 15
into that Roth 401k if that's the case
it makes it really easy do you have a
house
I do okay do you have anything left on
the mortgage
no oh wow it's very good what's the
housework
um it's probably worth like 65 70. cool
very good shape and is that where you
plan on retiring in that house
um no I mean I can but no do you want to
move upgrade in-house what's what would
be the goal I
where I am I would just like to move um
to a different location all together
okay like out of state well as far as
the baby steps go you would be in what
we call baby step seven which is the
final step build wealth and give and so
now is a great time to start to really
ratchet up your investing and that means
you could invest more than 15 and so you
could a great goal for you would be to
max out your 401K at work
and there's catch-up contributions now
that you're 50.
okay and so you want all the tax
advantaged accounts you can get matches
the best do you ever match with your
employer
no we did but they don't do the match
anymore okay so then Roth would be our
next best bet is utilize all the Roth
accounts we can which means a Roth IRA
and your Roth 401k if you can Max both
of those out you're you're going to be
in great shape
okay so just max out the rock into 401.
okay and I would get in touch with a
smartvester pro I don't know you know
what bank this is they may be fine
people at the bank but the bank is also
trying to sell that bank's products and
they might try to pitch you on things
that I would not recommend and so I
would get a second opinion from a smart
investor Pro you can connect with one of
those at ramseysolutions.com and they're
not tied to any One Bank
okay because that's who I have I went
through the smart Vesta Pro and that's
how I got the financial advisor I had
off with the um
Roth okay
well I would take their advice and you
still make the decisions make sure the
ball's in your court they're not going
to do anything for you they're just
going to educate you on your options and
then after that you go yep let's do that
I want to put my money in these mutual
funds and these index funds and uh you
should be in in better shape than you
would have been without investing so I
would put your savings also in a high
yield savings account right now it's
just with your local bank
yes okay look into some high-yield
savings accounts online we mentioned
some earlier in the show there's a bunch
out there Ally and Marcus are some that
our team members use here and that can
help your money grow up four percent
without locking it into one of those CDs
which are not I'm not a fan of
thank you for the call Shea appreciate
it all right let's get one more in with
Haley Haley welcome to the show
Hi how are you we are doing great what's
your question
um so I'll try to make a quick
um so I'm a full-time critical care
nurse I've been a nurse for uh nine
years I've been working mad over time
ever since covid and I actually got an
opportunity to switch careers this past
fall to become a high school teacher at
a vocational uh School teaching Allied
Health and so I was really excited to do
that because we were out of debt um we
were making our way towards our
emergency fund
um so I felt comfortable doing that
um but now the income has really slowed
down and it's we're comfortable but I
just can't we can't get past baby step
three I just feel like it's going so
slow I'm used to working so much
overtime and it's just very discouraging
so I'm just wondering how to deal with
that
um and if I should just go back to my
other career where I was making a ton of
money
well do you like this career better are
you passionate about this one versus not
caring about the old one
I am I'm passionate about both so I
actually do still work at the hospital
per diem so I work about two shifts a
month
um so that definitely helps and then I
can work in the summer
um I I love both jobs there's ups and
downs to both
um I just kind of needed a change after
working so much through like covet and
everything
um so I am passionate about this job
it's just the income is definitely
um
a bigger hit than I anticipated how much
is the hit
um so I mean working overtime at the
hospital uh last year I made 130 000 and
now I'm down to 71 000. so because based
off my yeah but based off my base salary
I was as a nurse I was 83 000 so I
figured taking the what 12 13 000 hit
wouldn't be so hard because we were out
of debt we were doing good and I could
still make up some overtime at the
hospital so it's it's not so like we're
comfortable we're making our bills and
everything but I just what's your
household income total
um so with base pay
um as a teacher I'm making 71 000
um I can make about 15 000 still at the
hospital and then my husband makes 55
000. okay is there an opportunity for
your husband to make more if he switched
careers
um assistant EMT so there is room for
overtime there
um he usually so he works full time too
um he does most of like the caretaking
of our son so I'm usually the one who
kind of picks up the overtime
um just because it's it's more hourly so
it makes more sense well you're going to
be out of this baby step three slog real
soon so I want you to make a long-term
decision that's right for you so I don't
want you to go back to the old job
there's a reason you took this new one
and so I want you to dig deep and go yes
this was the right choice we're just
feeling the pinch we keep getting these
emergencies that keep popping up but you
can definitely live off 120 something
thousand dollars a year with no debt
which is where you guys are at and so it
just looks you got to look at the budget
and go what how does our life look
different now that we took this pay cut
and is it worth the choice we made
great you're still going forward you're
just going forward at a slower rate and
that's okay
yeah I think that's the hardest part
it's just much slower now so it's like
an adjustment well stick it out for six
more months and if you guys are still
not making the progress go back to the
other job since you you like that one as
well thanks for the call that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show in the books my
thanks to Jade warshaw my co-host all
the guys in the booth keeping the show
afloat and you America thanks for tuning
in until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
foreign
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]